Good morning everyone, and happy Wednesday.
I bring to you this ad for Avant.
They're going to Jamaica.
Well, they're supposed to be there already
from the 9th to the 11th.
And I just wanted to pop on here to give my 2 cents.
Now, y'all know I don't promote or promote any company.
I always look at experiences
because everybody's experience is different.
And I also want people to be very much aware
that these company companies are pro profit companies.
So what does that mean?
They look out for themselves first.
And so you, as the nurse who is signing up,
should also look out for her or himself as well.
I had posted it on my stories on Instagram,
and an avant nurse reached out to me
and told me her experiences.
Y'all can pause to read.
She also highlighted that
because the process takes so long, new grads.
Because they're allowing new grads to sign up,
that you guys would still be able to get
01:59 years experience,
which you still have to have in the hospital.
As I always finish up with saying,
health care in the US is changing.
So ensure that all the information that you get,
if you go through some of my videos,
I tell you all
some of the questions that you can ask these agencies.
Make sure you research,
research, research,
research, research
for wherever you guys are going or get placed
so that you are well aware of
The hospital and its system. And how.
Why is it that you have to be an immigrant
that comes to feel a need in that system?
Sometimes it's because the system is so broken,
and they can't get their own
American nurses to do the work.
Why it is that they do hire us.
And I'm not bashing anybody or any company.
I just want everyone to be very much aware,
so that when you come here,
it's not a mine.
Never knows
that is there to happen.
Whenever I wear
something happen.
If anybody else has any other experience
with any other company,
I would love to hear what your experience are like,
and I will post them here.
Um, but I hope whoever gets to go to this
that's happening in Jamaica as well,
you guys could DM me,
let me know what the process was
and how it was for you guys
and for all of those who are intending to go.
I wish you guys all the best
and cannot wait to see you here in the US
as a US are